انضموا الينا من بيروت العميل الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سيد الياس هل
دخلت جبل بخموت في استاتيكو ميداني
الان في ظل التطورات التي نتابعها ميدانيه
حسن
الاستاتيكو هو ما يقال عنه الكلب مينيشن
يعني نقطه الذروه او نقطه الامتداد الاقصى
للمهاجم هذا ما تسعى اليه القوات
الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن مخموض لانها اصبحت
رمزا اساسيا سياسيا اكثر منه عسكريا لانها
مكلفه اليوم يبدو هذا وصلنا الى مرحله ليس
بعد ولكن يبقى قدره فاجنر مع الدعم الروسي
من الجيش الروسي اذا كانت هناك العلاقه
جيده للاستكمال السيطره على مخموته ولكن
بالمعنى بخموت هي جزء من الخط الذي يمتد
بنسبته وحتى اوغليدار ولكن هناك مشكله
ذخائر كما هو معروف
يعني لكلا الجانبين الاوكراني الاوكراني
والروسي
مشكله الزخائر هي مشكله
بالمصنعين الروسي
لاوكرانيا نحو الغربي لاوكرانيا ولكن
الاساس حسن هي العلاقه بين بيجوجين وزاره
الدفاع والدعم الذي يطلبه وعدم نيله لهذا
الدعم وكانه هناك محاوله لاستنزاف فاجنر
كي لا تكون قادره بعد معركه مخموت هذا اذا
سقطت مخمود ان يكون قادرا على لعب دور
عسكري وبالتالي ترجمه هذا النصر العسكري
الى نصر سياسي في مرحله لاحقه لماذا بدا
بدل الان ان التقدم الروسي اصبح بطيئا
يعني لم نعد نسمع
تلك البيانات السابقه عن سيطره وتقدم روسي
باتجاه بخموت في شرق باخموت او حتى الضغط
من من الغرب كل هذا لم نعد نسمعه في
الاونه الاخيره
يبدو حسن ان الجبهه كلها مشتعله وكانه
الهدف الروسي هو اشغال القوات الاوكرانيه
على خط يمتد اكثر من 600 كيلو متر
لتثبيتها في اماكنها
استنزافها ومنعها من التحضير للهجوم
المرتقب اما فيما خص مخبوط فهناك
الامتداد الاقصى كما قلت او القلب
الاستنزاف الكثير لقوات فاجنر والعلاقه
المهترئه او التي ليست ثابته او المهتزه
بين التنسيق الميداني بجهد وزاره الدفاع
طيب نقطتنا اود ان اسالك بشانهما الاولى
عوده خيرسون الى الواجهه
القصف في خرسون وزياره الرئيس بوتين الى
شبه جزيره القرم كيف قراتها
الزياره حسن اربعه مؤشرات مهمه
العدل محكمه الجرائم الدوليه للاي سي سي
حكما على الرئيس بوتين اثنين حادثه
المسيره ثلاثه زياره الرئيس تشيي وبالتالي
هذه الامور كلها مجتمعه وكانه يقول شخصيا
كانت المقابله مخصصه ان تكون افتراضيا
ولكن زارها شخصيا للتثبيت ان هذا امر خط
احمر لا يمكن الحديث عنه هذا شيء مهم
شكرا
جزيلا لك العميل الياس حناء الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي احدثتنا من بيروت